同学们好。
咱们这节课讲一个同学们这段时间呼声最高。
关心的一个问题。
AI创作。
怎么用AI写剧本呢？怎么用AI写故事呢？
关于这件事情啊，同学们已经问过我很多问题了，包括上课的时候直播的时候。
今天统一解答一下，先解答最重要的一个问题。
我用不用AI写剧本。
我身边。
的编剧。
呃。
我能观测到的50%都以上都在用。
整个行业来说，我觉得30%也开始用了。
只不过当然了，用的程度不同，以我个人为例。
在一年多以前，我们基本上是用它来查资料。
对吧我们说这个他对一些资料了解的不用那么熟，现在的话就深深度应用了啊，深度应用。所以说用。
得用。
好用。
这是。
我们的态度。
那么接下来就第二个问题，很多同学。
问过无数次的问题，哎呦，那既然用AI创作，那编剧是不是要失业了？
他会不会取代人类呀，对吧？取代编剧，取代创作呢？
我们说这种技术威胁论啊，在每一次新技术出现的时候啊都会有。
不用担心，我还是那句话。
呃，AI不会取代编剧，它只是换一种工具来创作，它有可能取代的是不用AI的编剧。
你拒绝使用就好像那个会计以前打算盘是吧？然后呢，现在是用计算器和计算机来做会计。你说我还是坚持打算盘，那你有可能被淘汰了。
所以淘汰的不是会计这个岗位，是淘汰坚持打算盘的会计。
AI也是这样啊，创作者永远不会被淘汰啊。
它只是一个工具的变革。当然这个变革很巨大。
他会把生产方式也。
颠覆了啊，因为我们说。
工具威胁论、技术威胁论啊不要害怕，但是人工智能确实是一个颠覆型的工具。
以我们创作者为例啊。
呃。
确实有巨大的改变。
同学们，以前我们说我们对编剧要求有哪几个能力啊？
同学们记不记得我刚开始给你们讲课的时候啊，我说一个优秀的编剧，一个优秀的创作者啊，要有。
共情力。
是吧然后想象力。
表达力。
执行力。
啥意思呢？你首先。
得是一个共情性认格呀，你能知道别人怎么想，你的感情才细腻，对吧？你要知道角色怎么想，观众怎么想，不同的角度怎么想共情力，然后想象力脑子里面得有。
发散性的思维是吧？得有百各种白日梦，得有对画面的各种想象啊，想象力。然后表达力你还是得把。
这些东西写出来嘛，你光在你脑子里面不行呀，有些同学文采就稍微差点意思，总是写不出画面感，总是写不出身临其境的感觉。我说表达力。
也是一个创作者需要的，再就是执行力。
执行力啥意思啊？我以前说过，我说一个如果是刚入门的编剧啊，如果是一个新人编剧，最重要的先判断执行力。
为啥十个编剧，9个托？
很多编辑有拖延症刚。
或者是新手写了很多开头都没写完，执行力不行。
你如果是个新人，执行力搞不好最重要。
我们说你看这是我们以前。
判断一个编距啊这四个等。
同学们。
现在用AI工具来辅助写作的话，注意啊，我说的是辅助写作。
我们的态度永远不是让AI替你写啊，AI辅助你写的话，这四个能力。
不重要。
因为aiI。
他的共情比你细腻，他能写出来的情感比你细。
他的想象力绝对比你好。
他的表达力我跟你说，他能模仿任何的文风，任何的文采。
他的非常的华丽的表达，身临其境的感觉。
执行力就更不用说了，对吧？以前写一个剧本。
最短也要几个月，现在。
几天就能写出来。
几分钟写个几千字很正常。
当然了，你得筛选修改啊，但是它的执行力。
远大远超人类1000倍。
所以说这四个能力不重要。
那有些同学说，哎呀，那不就是任何阿猫狗都能写了吗？错。
我们需要新的能力了。
判断力。
然后下指令的沟通能力。
其实是沟通能力判断能力下指令的沟通能力。然后最后你要验收，你要审美，你要知道什么是好的，你得吃过见过见赏。
这三个能力变得非常的重要。
当然了，如果你是你原本就是一个非常成熟，非常牛编剧的话，这三者的能力原本也在。
你要判断你要啥写啥，你要写什么赛道，写什么题材，这个故事适合写成什么题材，你最起码先有个判断力嘛。
然后你再下指令，你会沟通，对吧？你你明确的跟他说你想要什么。
然后呢，他给你N多种选择，多次修改以后，你得把你想要的给抓取出来。
你得有你审美啊。
同学们，你看啊。
以前我们做一个编剧是一个人一个生产力啊。
你既是你的老板，又是你的员工啊。
现在你看员工要干的事儿全部交给。
人工智能。
你只需要做。
甲方应该做的事儿。
明白吗？所以说不是AI创作之后，不是没有门槛了，是换门槛。
但是利好哪些人啊，同学们。
就立好以前那些有想法，没方法。
有创作冲动，没有创作行动的那部分人。哎，这部分人。
搞不好就翻身了。
执行力比较差，但是脑子很活泛，是吧？想法很多，但是写不出来哎。
这群人搞不好就。
对他们来说，人工智能是个非常大的利好。
但是还是那句话啊，技术威胁论每每次有新技术的时候都有这种讨论，是吧？互联网出来之后，我们说哎呀，现在发邮件那么容易。
不像以前写封信是吧？信件很慢，但是爱很浓。现在是什么垃圾信息这么多，就就是对吧？没有温度，对吧？汽车刚刚发明的时候也是哎呀，现在到哪去速度很快，但是失去了沿途的风景，没有温度，是吧？电商刚出来的时候，也是说哎呀这个电商。
把这个消费盲目消费是吧？呃盲目交易。
呃，不像以前买的东西，对吧？精挑细选品很高。
我们说新的东西出来的之候都会有这样的。
技术威胁论啊。
我们不去判断是非。
为啥？因为。
互联网出来的时候，确实大家垃圾信息很多呀，垃圾邮件垃圾微信很多，确实没有显息有温度呀，咱承认呀，但是你拦得住吗？
连你奶奶现在都在发微信，你拦不住的呀。
高效率的东西是拦不住的。所以我们不去讨论它的威胁。
每次技术更新都有这种威胁，对吧？我们不去讨论这件事情，汽车就是能够更快的把我们送到某个地方。
互联网就是能够更快更高效的传播信息。
AI就是能够更高高效的创作内容。
所以我们不去讨论对错，我们只享受它的红利。
这种技术威胁论啊，我们不去讨论，为啥？因为说到底。
AI是个工具，你是老板，你说了算。
至于他什么能自我生长，那个什么那些科幻片的事情，我们就不去讨论了。好吧，互联网刚刚出来的时候也讨论过这些事情。我跟你说，蒸汽机发明的时候就都讨论过这些事情，机器人威胁乐以前也有。
所以这个就不去。
我们说点实惠的。
我们用哪个工具去创？
工具。
同学们，现在有很多关于。
协作的工具。
这个是AI写短句的，那个是AI写剧本的，这个是AI写小说的。
统一回答一下啊，同学们。
我们主流编剧现在依然在用通用模型。
通用的语言大模型。
也就是。
Gepick。
GPT。
文心怡言、豆包这类。
大冒仙。
几个原因。第一，现在那些垂直领域的工具。
你可以理解都是仓促上。
以噱头为主。
收一波会员费。
他的设定啊，因为我是我熟悉好几个公司，对吧？都在做这种。因为你想他们如果AI写剧本，AI写短剧。
呃，很难绕过我，对吧？很多人来找过我这个因为我既是编剧教学的头部，又是这种理性创作的。
这个算是代言人吧，是吧？
所以说这些工具的运行逻辑啊我比较清楚。
坦白说，不如大模型好用，它只是傻瓜式的操作。
傻瓜式的操作输出的内容千篇一律。
我还是那句话，我们不是让aiI替我们创。
我们是指导他。
要求他装作，我们是老板。
所以说我们愿意用到一个非常聪明的模型。
而不是一个非常傻瓜的模型。
明白吗？
再加上啊这些。
垂直类的工具。
也不稳定，因为公司也比较小。
还要付会员费。
输出的东西呢算力也不足啊，所以说这都是弊端。再加上还有个版权界定的问题。你如果让别人让工具替你创作，而不是你主导创作，你主导修改的话，这个版权到时候也麻烦。
好吧，所以在这里咱们统一用。
通用模型。
我本人啊用deeps，当然了，你说豆腐包文心一言能比deeps差多少呢？
倒也不明显啊，一点儿也不明显。呃，就是一种感官上吧，就感觉好像梁文峰比较可爱。
对吧但其实都差不多啊都差不多。
那我们同学还要问了，那输出的东西。
嗯。
有那么好吗？我们单看细节啊，看单项啊，比95%以上的创作者要强。
比如说具体的能力啊，甚至按理说啊具体的能力应该比99%的创作者都强。
但是综合输出的东西它一定有问题。
综合输出的东西啊一定有问题。
网上有句话说，AI写出来的东西有AI味儿是吧？要去味。
我们创作的时候就不存在这个问题。我们职业编剧用A写的时候就不存在这个问题。因为我们不是说丢给他一个指令，让他通篇输出，对吧？给我写一篇爆款访文剧本，给我写一个商业电影剧本，我要3亿票房，你下这种指令，人家咋给你写啊？
可能的。所以我们在创作的时候啊。
我们是拒绝使用指令包。
所有关于指令包的那些方法论。
一定要摒弃啊，一定不能用那些方法。所谓的哎，我给你20句话，你照20句话输出给他，他就可以帮你输出一篇成品的小说，你就不用动了。哎呀，这种千万不要信啊。
这种方法论枪不要信。
同学们，你从逻辑上简单思考一下这个指令包。
是傻瓜似的，不用动脑子。
然后这个工具。
是免费的。
你用一个没有技术含量傻瓜式的指令，配上一个人人都可以用的免费的工具，加在一块就能挣钱。你想啥呢？
现实吗？
不现实。
好吧，所以一定要不要相信指令包。
我们呢用的是。
沟通的方法下指定的方法，你可以跟他聊，对吧？也可以向他提问题，也可以向他下命令，也可以让他扩展。
按照我们以前写剧本的顺序，先讨论选题，对吧？再把它扩展成一个正式的故事创意，然后再扩展成一个故事梗概，然后详细的设计人物，设计主角，设计伙伴，设计爱情设计对手。
然后再凑齐这些故事所有的要素是吧？然后再按照故事的20个节拍去码。我们说是按照我们以前创作的步骤一步一步去扩展。
这样的话可以有效的去AI味。但是。
还是要强调一下，即便是这样写出来的东西，也不能拿来就用，必须要修改。我给大家讲几几个AI现在做的不那么好的地方。所以我刚才说啊，如果看单项，它比我们99%的人都强。但是如果综合出出来一个东西。
其实它是很难及格的，就综合你让他一下输出个几千字，上万字是很难及格的。为啥呢？因为里面有硬伤，比如说人物的连续性问题。
他写的这个人物啊，前面的人设和后面的热有时候不连续，是吧？不稳定。
同学们，你如果懂点AI这个运行的逻辑，你就知道是咋回事是吧？咱们这节课不是讲技术的，只讲现象。
第二呢，有时候呢某种人设过于连续。
就比如说他认为这个人在有某种。
行为。
就一直重复，对吧？他认为这个人就应该。
每次都应该在怎么样？比如说这个人获取秘密。
是因为。
他神出鬼没，能偷听到别人说话。
然后每次获取信息都是偷听到别人说话，你看就重复。然后呢。
这也是一种AI味，还有一种AI味很极限。
也就是说，AI是他能想到的最优解，还是那句话啊，你要理解AI创作的逻辑啊，AI特别是语言模型啊，它是根据词词语和词语，其实不是词语啊，是token啊，token和token之间的最大。
最优匹配最大概率来。
进行创作，进行输出内容的啊。
呃，说起来很机械化，但其实人脑也是这么个逻辑。
人组织语言啊也是这么个逻辑。
也就是说。
他永远在选最优解。
那么就会出现一个情况，他所有的戏剧化给你拉满。
比如说我们。
今天写了呃今天刚刚写了一个东西啊，要写这个我们的这个男二为团队牺牲了是吧？
其实这个牺牲吧可以不一定非得死，对吧？
可以是这个这个这个这个付出一些代价啊，当然也可以死，因为是个灾难片。
然后呢，用AI创作这场戏的时候呢，AI就把把这个人写成了一个孤胆英雄，他咋死的那原文啊。
就是这里有一段电线要抢修。
我们这个男二发现这个电线与电线之间连不上了。
会影响团队的整体目标，甚至会团队损失很大，损失很多人命。我们的。
男二用自己的肉肉身连接了这两段电线，然后让电从自己身上通过是吧？
然后拯救了团队，我们说这个。
如果是动画片啊。
好像看起来挺就挺厉害。
但是如果是真人的片子就过于戏剧化。
就是。
拉到极限了，当然你不能怪他，因为你这个这个超级助手啊，共情力、想象力、表达力、执行力实际上确实挺强的。
啊，这段戏其实还是。
场面感还是很足的，但是呢。
过于夸张了，我们要往回收一收啊，往回收一收。
我们说这些都是AI在写作的时候容易出现的问题，重复性的剧情啊也会有。
重复性的剧情，重复性的人设，对吧？
然后那个每个人都有精神创伤啊，我们说这是一种我们说这几年啊商业片我们确实是比较鼓励主角有一定的。
精神创伤啊，因为外在创伤现在已经很少写了嘛。
内在创商比较流行。
但是他不能每个角色都有创伤呀。
我们说这也是这个这个AI味啊，AI的一些机器的味儿会有一些这样的情况。
但是按照咱们的方法啊，可以有效的避免。因为你是那个鉴赏的人呀。
你说了算呀，而不是全部交给他，用一个指令包都解决。
那样写出来的东西啊，及格都很难啊，及格都很。
所以说。
咱们啊一定要用通用模型，然后用按照步骤去沟通，对吧？呃，可以呃探讨，可以提要求，可以让他扩展，甚至写完了还可以让他。
逐段修改嘛，包括台词的风格化，对吧？它容易所有人说话风格一样，对不对？让他根据人设再去呃修改风格啊，甚至可以仿写是吧？比如说我们这个故事是写实题材，我们就希望他像我们是药神的那种叙事风格，对吧？这种都是可以做到的啊。
然后我们现在用AI呢。
都能干什么呢？我们最近啊用AI之前就一直用AI写剧本。最近呢用AI也在写短剧写电影啊，写各种题材，包括写小说。
长篇的小说也好啊，然后这个新媒体文这些短篇的也好，都在用它写。更重要的是什么啊？我们现在用它来创作短视频教。
因为短视频脚本啊。
其实。
他的。
规律性更强。
对吧你想要出爆款，你想要玩播率，对吧？规律性更强，赛道也非常明确。所以说用AI写短视频剧本，我们现在也经常用。
然后再跟大家提一下啊，关于AI生图和生视频。
AI声图和声视频啊未来也有广阔天地啊，虽然不是我们编剧主力探讨的，但由于我们有时候会生成一些内容，生成一些短视频，然后呢给他配点图，甚至配点简单视频。在这里跟大家说一下啊。
AI声屠的指令啊其实可以反推。
也就是说你想要一个什么图？因为AI生图的那些平台啊，指令比较复杂。
需要有一定的呃这个门槛。但是呢你可以把你的大白话，你想要个什么图，大白话告诉deep seek。
然后要deep seek帮你翻译成。
比如说我们用made journey是吧？即便是用可灵是吧？这种它指令都是比dept这种语言语言工具大模型的工具要要复杂一些。你可以想要什么图，用大白话跟dept说，然后让他帮你生成指令啊，甚至为一个图给给dep seek，哎，这生成这种图应该。
收指令，我们说这是一种技巧啊。
另外呢，纹身视频。
我现在要一个视频。
怎么弄呢？同学们，因为生视频啊，你自己试一下就知道了啊，用文字生成视频比文字生成文字。我们说我们AI创作啊是文字生成文字，我们说的也是话，让它输出的也是语言，对吧？
但是纹身视频啊更不稳定。
他的镜头，他的人的形象，人就所谓的人的人设嘛。
这个画面的流畅度啊都会出现不稳定的情况。
包括风格呃会不稳定。所以说直接文声视频目前你如果傻瓜操作，很难实现有价值的创作啊，我们现在当然也有文声成视频的需求啊，因为现在也有视频这个AI短句嘛。
基本上啊都是先生图。
先纹生图，然后用图再去生食品。
这样的话有一个基准。
也就是说这个图达到你满意了，稳定了，你让它再动起来，怎么个动法，怎么个运镜法，再告诉他，然后生成视频，这样的话可以比较稳定啊。当然了，生视频也用可灵就够了啊，暂时都够了。
如果你有声视频的需求啊，你你要知道，不要直接纹声视频啊，有个基准图会比较好。
当然这个我们目前啊用的没有那么多啊，给大家提一下。因为很多同学问到。
总之啊。
总之啊这个。
AI这个东西啊，它的技术在不断的迭代，对吧？会出来什么新的方法了，或者是垂直领域的工具做的很好了啊，我们再告诉大家啊。
呃，目前它发展非常快啊，迭代也非常快。我们要呃随时更新自己的知识啊，咱们这个。
也给大家整理了啊关于AI创作的一些知识啊，在这里啊。
我想跟大家强调一点。
就是关于。
新的技术啊新的技术出来之后，新的趋势跑出来之后啊。
我每次都发现一个问题。
同学们提那么多问题，每次都提很多质疑是吧？这个东西到底行不行？它行不行？它会不会就是一阵风，对吧？它会不会就是取代我们人类，他是不是邪恶的？为什么总有这样的想法呢？
是因为每次新的东西出来的时候啊。
家有一种抗拒的心态。
不愿意尝试新的东西。
这一点啊是我比较痛心的啊我比较痛心的。
因为。
每次趋势跑出來之后啊。
其实是有一个非常友好，非常巨大的窗口期的。
你想想看互联网刚刚出来的时候。
电商刚刚出来的时候。
自媒体刚刚出来时候，短视频刚刚出来的时候直播刚刚出来的时。
造富了多少人？
因为他有一个非常友好的窗口期，我称之为公平的窗口期。也就是说在那个阶段，你只要进去啊，就能参与公平竞争。
搞不好就可以逆袭，搞不好就可以翻身。而且逆袭和翻身的概率非常大。你想想看，如果你在03年做了电商。
你在05年做了自媒体。
你在01年写了网络小说。
你在14年。
搞了直播，你在16年做了视频短视频。
你肯定翻身嘛。
对不对？所以说每次新技技术出来的时候啊，是有公平的窗口期的。但是呢咱们很多同学。
就是在质疑中，在犹豫中把他给耽误了。
这个是候比较痛心的。
在这里我想说AI呀。
之前。
这些所谓的窗口期啊。
来的更猛烈。
因为他是一个。
人脑级别的生产力解放。
他取代的是人脑呀。
你可以类比，就像工业革命取代的是人的肌肉。我们说蒸汽机机器发明的时候啊，1840年机器发明的时候啊。
在那之前，人类生产。
人类改变生活，改造地球，用的是我们的肌肉。
拥有什么肉体的力量，但是机器发明出来之后呢，彻底颠覆了这个世界。
也就是说你穿越到1840年，你告诉一个码头工人，你告诉那个最强壮的码头工人说你这身肌肉有可能会没用。
他会觉得你疯了。
我一辈子作为最有劲儿的人，在这个码头就是挣钱最多的人，我怎么会没用了呢？
不理解。
但是确实呀你再有劲儿，你干得过挖掘机吗？
看不过的呀。
所以说这就是颠覆型的一种改变。
那么现在人工智能取代的是我们的人脑，或者是它是我们人脑的放大器。
就相当于挖掘机和肌肉，你可以理解你现在那点那点智商，那点知识。因为我们这一代人都生活在知识改变命运。聪明的人就是牛这些观点之下，就像那个肌肉大的1840年的那个大肌肉壮汉，他认为肌肉就是正义呀。
对吧你说了些什么呀？你什么还有人比我厉害。
不理解就好像咱们这一代人觉得聪明就是正义呀，从小我们就这么被灌输的呀，也要被颠覆喽。
因为能力换了呀。
能力换了。
所以说AI会带来的颠覆性的东西很多。
是吧它是一个巨大的窗口期，它会有一个比较长的窗口期，机会很多的一个窗口期，你不要再犹豫了。
赶紧学吧。
不要觉得哎呀这个东西到底行不行啊，low不low啊，对吧？我们经常会觉得新的东西low。
对吧直播刚出来的时候，我们觉得他low，我觉得哎呀直播的人都是网络卖什么，对吧？电商刚出来的时候觉得low，对吧？甚至于喊打喊杀，把电商都灭了，中国的经济就好了，实体就起来。其这是一些很错误的想法。我跟大家讲，互联网刚出来的时候，中央台都有个节目讨论互联网到底对这个世界好不好？
因为新东西出来的时候啊，大家因为对他的恐惧，因为对固有赛道的坚持，因为那些既得利益者的舆论引导，大家会对一个新技术进行攻击。
造一些阴谋论，对吧？
造一些这种想。
没有必要。
我们这一代人啊。
非常受一句电影台词的影响，姜文导演在让子子弹飞里面。
说有一句台词说要站着把钱挣了同学们。
我们很多人说这句台词影响。
觉得。
如果一件事情虽然挣钱，但是如果别人说他low，我就不做了。
我认为影响不好。
首先。
姜文导演肯定不是这个意思。
为啥呢？
因为。
他在让子弹飞这个电影里面，他挣钱是咋挣的？
抢劫假冒县长。
有哪件事情是合法的？我想请问。
这叫站着把钱挣了吗？
其实他也在走捷径，也在走歪门邪道。
更何况，我们现在应用新技术不是歪门邪道。
不是捷径。
我们学aiI不是想走捷径呀。
我们是提高生产力呀，提高创作力呀。
就像我们如果做电商，做短视频不是走捷径呀，有什么可low的呢？
同学们，我从我个人角度啊。
我一直在做lowlo的事情，我第一批做的短视频。
我是中国。
第一部网剧的创作者。
我还做过网大。
做个自媒体是吧？也做个直播。
这些所谓大家觉得哎呀喽喽的东西我一向不去抗拒同学们。
你知道為什麼吗？
兄弟们。
给大家讲个故事啊。
我小学的时候。
曾经有好几年。
在路边卖冰棍。
90年代啊，我妈下岗了。
当清洁工。
收入不高。
所以呢我卖冰棍儿贴补一下家用。
夏天啊确实很热。
很累。
咱同学们。
我一点也不觉得苦，因为赚的钱还可以。在那个年代，你只要愿意。
做点马。
赚钱是可以的，我唯一最难受的地方是什么？
我们是一个小县城。
我经常会碰到同学，我每次碰到同学，我都特别不好意思。
特别尴尬。
如果远远看到他们啊，我就躲起来。
如果他们已经走过来了啊，已经非要跑过来问我买冰棍了，我就一直低着头不抬头，对吧？借他们的钱给他们冰棍，我就不抬头。
很愚蠢的一种。
很消极的一种抵抗方式是吧？其实谁不知道。
怎么回事？同学们现在有很多这个爽文啊重生。如果我穿越到90年代，当时的我，我会怎么做呢？
我会抱着箱子去学校里面买。同学们。
我作为一个学习很好的小朋友。
我家里条件不好，我要卖冰棍，这是什么？
这是人设。
我们学校有几千个老师和孩子，这是什么？这是流量。你觉得他们会不买我的冰棍吗？
这是变现。
我为什么要害怕？
我为什么要不好意思啊？
人只有在弱小的时候，才会为自己的弱点感到自卑。同学们，我现在长大了，我强大了。
并不是说我没有弱点。
我其实还在卖冰棍。
我一直在卖冰棍。
只不我不害怕。
自卑了。
同学们，你如果。
还是赚不到钱，或者没有找到赚钱的诀窍。你反思一下，是不是你还在害怕。
还在自悲呢。
搞不好，你现在依然是那个在路边低着头，不敢抬头卖冰棍的小孩。
这是我的真实的经历。
希望能给大家一点启发。
下课吧。